[Música]
y la huelga indefinida comenzó el 6 de
julio desde entonces maestros de todo
panamá han liderado multitudinarias
protestas a las que se han unido
trabajadores de construcción y miembros
de comunidades indígenas para exigirle
al gobierno que intervenga en los
precios del mercado en medio de una
elevada inflación exigimos aumento
general de salario reducción en los
precios de los medicamentos que se
acaben la monopolio de los medicamentos
que tienen ser senado al pueblo panameño
reducción en los precios de combustible
y disminución de los precios a la
canasta básica
[Aplausos]
ante las peticiones de los panameños y
luego de reunirse con sindicatos y
organizaciones sociales
el presidente laurentino cortizo anunció
que congelará el precio del galón del
combustible para vehículos particulares
a partir del 15 de julio y espera calmar
el enojo de la población mediante un
decreto quiero anunciar que he decidido
ampliar la medida de congelar el precio
del galón de combustible en 395 para los
vehículos particulares
a nivel nacional a partir del 15 de
julio
igualmente he convocado para mañana el
consejo de abín ete para aprobar un
decreto que congelará el precio de diez
productos adicionales de la canasta
básica otra piedra la protesta que se
hace más fuerte con el pasar de los días
se ha transformado en cierre de vías
enfrentamientos con la policía y hasta
un paro educativo por parte de los
profesores